Now, every problem is a little different,
and all of the database products are a little different,
so most of what I'm going to cover in this lesson applies
in the general case, but not always.
But one of the things that does apply in almost every general case is this notion of tables,
so let's say we're building a site like Reddit that's going to take links from users,
and we will store them in a database and allow users to vote on those links,
and then we'll show what's the most popular.
We'll probably have a table for links,
and this link is made up of a number of things.
It's got an ID.
It's probably got a number of votes.
It's got the user that submitted the link.
It's got a date of when the link was submitted,
and it probably has a title.
This is what we'd display on the site, and a URL.
These are all called columns of the database.
Columns are basically the properties that
make up a particular type, so in this case, our type is a link.
That's what we're going to call our table, and these are columns.
Now, every entry of a link in this table is called a row,
so we might have a link that looks something like this.
Here would be an example ID, 5.
It's just an integer.
The number of votes that this link has.
The user that submitted it. This is an interesting column.
We'll come back to this.
The date of when the link was submitted and a title and a URL.
Let's talk about each of these columns.
Now, this thing in its entirety is called a row,
and a row is one instance of an element in this table,
so we'll have many, many rows for all of the links that are submitted.
And my label isn't very good here, but these are the columns.
Columns go down, rows go across.
Let's talk about each of these columns.
The ID column is important in almost all tables.
Generally every row will have an ID,
and this is how you refer to that row specifically.
This is link #5.
It's not required in most databases that you have something called an ID,
but it's really helpful, and in some databases, it is, in fact, required.
Usually it's an integer. It could be a string.
The database on Google App Engine allows you to use integers or strings.
This column here, votes, this column is also an integer.
This refers to the number of votes on this link.
This column here, user, is also an integer,
so this is a reference to the ID of the user who submitted the link,
so we may have another table called Users or User
that may have its own set of columns, one of which is an ID.
It may also have name and date
and maybe password.
There could be another table called User that stores all of our users,
and this column is just a reference to this other table,
and we'll come back more to these types of relationships later,
but just know that this is a common way of doing things.
Okay, so then we'll have our date column for the link,
and this probably has a type of date.
Not all databases support the date type, but the ones we'll be using in this class do,
and it's really handy to store this stuff.
And this is ultimately probably an integer, but depending on
the sophistication of the database, they may have a real date type.
And of course, we'll have the title,
which is a string.
This may also in some databases be known as text
or varchar or there's lots of ways of referring to it,
but it's basically just referring to this type, but it's just a string.
And URL is the same thing. It's also a string.
Our table is made up of--defined of columns,
and it's filled up with rows.
Every time a user submits something, we add a new row.
If another submission comes in--we may have 0 votes and submitted by user 27--
this table can have a lot of data in it.
Before we go into specific database stuff, let's work through some
examples in Python of how we might manipulate
this kind of structured data programming.